team rebounds eight assists for jokic  paul can't hit another chance here for  the nuggets down  14.  jokic putting it on the deck lost it  phoenix ball  [Applause]  jokic going nuts and he's going to get a  t  i'm going to be really honest i'm okay  with this technical for the last six  minutes  you're not the mvp if you don't if you  don't get it technical  why the night that you raised the trophy  and if you can see the emotion they  understand how important this game is  these final six minutes will dictate the  denver nuggets  season paul  sinks the free throw let's see richard  do you think there was a foul here  that wasn't no foul no it wasn't a foul  oh that wasn't a foul  [Applause]  i think jokic is frustrated because he's  gotten banged around a few times tonight  without a whistle  but there was nothing obvious to call a  foul there